après une période de la toussaint en
plan confinement l'année dernière les
fleuristes se réjouissent d'enfants
pouvoir retrouver leur clientèle dans
des conditions plus propices anémone une
boutique logé au coeur de montigny le
bretonneux à tout juste un an
heureusement l'année dernière ça a été
une grosse période ils ont beaucoup joué
le jeu pour nous soutenir dû à la peur
du cobp idées en plus de notre notre
ouverture toute
naissante comme chaque année les
fleuristes doivent mettre les bouchées
doubles pour tous à cette fête
traditionnelle marque un pic dans leurs
activités on a vraiment composé nous
mêmes tous ensemble des compositions
alors vous avez de l'ami donc ça c'est
pour le côté champêtre que moi
j'apprécie du giro fleix du lys du
chrysanthème bien évidemment un pour ce
week end pour le 1er novembre
composition et ornements floraux
deviennent fleurir les tombes certaines
variétés ou plus particulièrement la
cote qu'on retrouve beaucoup de
chrysanthèmes qui est la fleur par
excellence de la bruyère beaucoup de
brouillard de différents types de laits
les bords commencent aussi ce qu'on
appelle aussi la rose de noël
communément voilà de la pensée avec un
gagnant le chrysanthème est la plante
qu'on retrouve à cette période là c'est
fleury il en existe de plein de types et
de formes différentes et ça tient bien
et puis c'est pas c'est parce qu'ils
aussi de le plus onéreux après la
marguerite d'automne il faudra encore
attendre quelques semaines pour pouvoir
orner nos tables où nos maisons de
branche de gui ou de houe